so you have a ton of quick changes
people try and get me to do this thing
and
it's exhausting and I'm like I'm running
back there and I'm like I do you ever
Miss have you ever missed one a quick
change or have you ever like just come
out and been like well it wasn't all put
together I didn't quite make it yeah no
you know what I think that would be such
a fun game to do oh um you should yeah
that should be a game no I'm just I'm
Gonna Change challenges our next game on
this show I know
I you know want the audience to try out
the Quick Change challenge see how
quickly you can get out and back into
another set of clothes I'm telling you
it's thought out yeah well I've posted
the Billboard Award so that's the only
time I've Done Quick changes that are
like yeah it's like less than three
minutes sometimes or two minutes and
it's like super quick and it's like I
don't know if something breaks something
breaks you're like just pin it yeah
exactly there's lots of swearing in the
Quick Change yes 100 no we're really
classy that never happens
um screen swear fast yeah you have to
get out there so you've never like come
out on stage and just completely because
one time in my quick change they forgot
to
um do something they zipped me but
didn't do the and I jumped around a lot
on that tour and so my dress almost came
completely off and I
was Commando
so that that would have gone real
European beach real quick yeah yeah
caught it I caught it has anything ever
happened to you like that I've had
things like that happen I've had other I
think the biggest mishap I've had on
stage well actually the biggest mishap
I've had on say is with my horse one
time yeah my horse I was on stage
drops a big poop
and I mean it's big and it's steamy and
it's stinky you know
um I mean not for me I love the smell of
horse poop
everything I own smells like horse poop
but
um so but but it was just really awkward
you know and so I just had to say well
what happens
[Applause]
would have loved that being at that show
oh my gosh
[Music]
[Applause]